hi my name is David baron and I'm here
at the 2018 world from technology
conference and I'm here to talk about
computational thinking with the Wolfram
language what is computational thinking
why would you do that how you go about
doing it if you're an educator the
researcher or work in an organization or
just being a human being who wants to
learn how to do things more efficiently
and he lives a little bit happier life
check it out my name is Debbie duodenum
and among other things I'm an ambassador
for the computational thinking
initiatives and that's what I'll be
talking about here today so in this talk
I'll be walking through briefly what is
computational thinking why we would do
that and how we could do go about doing
that and that's kind of sharing some
resources more from language related
resources for educator researchers or in
Maine if you are working in and/or part
of any organization actually so be
working through a brief example of how
one can do you computational thinking in
k-12 education and at the end I'm gonna
share some updates from warm side of
things and share some resources that
hopefully you'll find helpful
so to warm up before this conference how
many of you have heard the term
computational thinking okay that's
that's that's good
it's more and more more hands showing up
every time that's that's a nice thing
how many of you have not heard the term
computational thing it's basically just
it's good to have some movement like
equally for everyone it's it's been a
long conference maybe a lot of sitting
and coding so remind my voice is little
down so really let me know if you can't
hear you know what I'm saying so the
term itself computational thinking it's
it's quite recent and as such its
definition this has been and it's still
kind of evolving and and there's
evolution to it but there so there are
some entities or organizations that have
defined it so for instance Google
defines computational thinking as
process of problem-solving that includes
variety of things but if you actually
google the first hit you probably will
get is Wikipedia's definition that is
Janette wings definition that
computational thing is the thought
processes involved in formulating a
problem and expressing its solutions in
such a way that a computer human error
machine can effectively be carried out
now they're more and more kind of focus
on on the ideology of computational
thinking and their even centers built
around at Carnegie Mellon they define
computational thinking as a way of
solving problems defining systems and
understanding human behavior drawing
drawing concepts on computer science
obviously the correct answer is given by
Wolfram Alpha so if you ask Wolfram
Alpha what is computational thinking
will tell you that computational
thinking is the mental process of
formulating concepts with enough clarity
and in a systematic enough way that one
can tell a computer how to do them and
kind of building up from that definition
of the computational thinking
initiatives kind of more a conceptual
way of computational thinking trains the
mind to see the ways in which the
special kill skills of ubiquitous modern
computational devices can be harnessed
to better understand the physical social
intellectual and cultural worlds we
inhabit kind of a point to make here is
that this definition indeed has kind of
evolved and from kind of problem solving
problems and formulating problems and
expressing its solutions going kind of
designing systems understanding human
behavior and all the way harnessing
these devices to better understand this
physical social intellectual and
cultural worlds we inhabit I kind of
like the the Wolfram definition it's it
is kind of the most broad of this and it
really really focuses or kind of gives
the idea how the whole ideology of
computational thinking can be really
applied to literally in anything that we
do but so why are we doing it or why
would we be doing it and so one way to
look at it is basically looking for
instance that the estimated operational
stock of industrial robots so this plot
is from international federal
robotics showing thousands of units per
year and if we look at it so basically
we see that that number has been
increasing up to now and for better or
worse it will likely continue to do so
so by 2020 we have over 300 0 3 million
operational industrial robots when
something is for better or worse I tend
to say let's make it for better shall we
and here I can quote PwC analysis this
year on impact of automation on jobs we
have to be looking at how we train our
young people and rescale workers so they
are ready to move into new roles at
technology like AI will create
particularly emphasizing the importance
of increased investment in lifelong
learning and Retraining and this has
huge impact on education and how we
think about education and teaching and
learning and and work in general so now
just a brief example of how you could go
about doing this this particle example
is targeted for middle schoolers and
middle school classes and but idea is
kind of to give a concrete example of
how you could what this ideology kind of
entails so you can start by asking for
instance something the real-world
application how secure is my bike lock
and you can say it up for instance
failing that your friend has forgotten
the word she used for her bike lock
however she remembers it is an English
word would you be able to help unlock
her bike the way you can set it up in a
classroom for instance yes you can
actually give these bike locks in and
then let's say form pairs or groups and
one of them will set up the lock and I
just try to you know different words to
to unlock that and after a while you
will come to realization that it is
actually a non-trivial problem highly
non-trivial problem and and then you can
start asking so how we could go about it
more systematically and more efficiently
and now this kind of depends now how you
actually go about
depends on the background of of the
audience and of the educators like how
much they actually know let's say about
programming coding Wolfram language and
so forth for the sake of this this
example we kind of one way of this let's
say that we can show there are some
functions built-in functions in a
welcome language that that can can be
helpful to address this for instance
there's the thing like we knew that she
used an English word so there is a
function word list that will give you
all the English words about 40 thousands
of them and then we can start forming
let's say a computational version of the
of the by clock and just make basically
take a string pattern where you have
like this is a simple example where you
have four dials and each dial has ABCDE
so the first letters will be here then
the second year third here and the
fourth one over here and now now you can
think of the the without having these
computers and computational devices what
you would need to do is basically take a
dictionary and go through all these
40,000 words pick up the four-letter
words from there and and the ones that
can be formed and for those ones that
can be formed from this combination that
would be a quite a daunting task to do
and especially if a large classroom of
kids and then you would have to have
like many many dictionaries and it would
take a lot of time but now we can
basically use something like this that
you can select from the word like
strings that match that that pattern and
then you can press leave to enter and
you get those words so this is kind of a
simple example so we had only a few few
letters do a simple walk but a kind of
the idea is that what we got what we
basically used was these three functions
lazy ok you can calculate the length of
that if you if you want it but we use
three functions and a few symbols and we
got to do something really concrete and
actually had a header like us would help
solve a real-world problem or a problem
that can be
and that can happen for these kids but
the the point here is that you don't
have to basically stop here like that
was like a small example but you can use
all the alphabets and that's where like
this idea of computational thinking and
the power of computing and computers
comes that you know you don't have to be
just constrained to simple examples like
here you can with a little bit of extra
effort you can kind of build a more
fancy bike lock where you have like
eight dials which all of them all the
all the letters of the alphabet so it's
a big one but but basically you can then
just use the same same function and then
you get all the possible combinations
and you quickly see that this would be
quite a daunting time to find all those
all those words from a dictionary book
for instance so that in this case you
had like five thousand nine hundred and
nineteen possibilities and again you
don't have to even step you don't have
to stop there you didn't use all I'm
originally from Finland so we add a
couple more how more letters there and
as a consequence and quite surprisingly
so in English you have about forty
thousand words
and in Finnish you have our seven
hundred thousand words that's slightly
it's not entirely in the sense correct
because that includes all the all the
the different cases of the words too but
in the sense that you have a lot of
different ways of expressing these
things but again it you can just do the
same things to look at it and then just
there it's calculating whether I was
surprised oh yeah yeah it is the reason
why it took a little longer because it
actually had to cover that seven hundred
thousand instead of 30,000 or 40,000
anyway but you will find a finer handed
in this case and see if it still
remembers that anyway you will find out
that you can apply it in to any number
of alphabets any languages like you
don't have to come
strange EG alphanumeric okay this is
still running this is one example of
what happens when you use computational
devices they all don't always behave the
way you would like them to or you would
expect them to and and that's that's
also okay like in the educational
situation that you are running this
class as a teacher and you know
something like this happens that there's
a process that keeps kind of going then
you know that's what that's the thing
that that can happen in real life and
then that's an educator you need to kind
of you know assess that situation and
basically here are some opportunities to
[Music]
wait if we get a response and kind of
this is also an opportunity for kids to
kind of learn that okay what what will
you do when something like this happen
and the process is so as an educator you
can kind of go through the steps what is
actually happening in the machine and I
think different kinds of things that you
can do about it if you're in this case
there is if nothing else helps you can
kind of go to control our Delta and the
Windows machine and end up tasks that's
so that's one way of solving solving
this thing and then you can kind of get
up there and see if you can get it up
back there but again that's so that's an
example of of a thing that can happen in
a real word for educators that things
don't work with technology as they as
you would like them to be and it's an
important step for for a teacher in a
classroom to be confident about that and
comfortable with that things don't
always go the way you like particularly
when you are using when you're coding
things and the kind of teeth it's an
educational moment for kids to learn
learn about that and not to be
frustrated and get stuck with that
anyway so that was an example of what
what
how you'd go could go about doing
computational thing in the middle school
classroom now see so that's a that's an
example an activity that kids can do in
in the classroom and let's see so and
this particular example was from the
computational thinking initiatives and
there is actually accessible online
where we have an lesson plan actually
structured around this so it's not just
having an empty notebook but for the
educators there is kind of information
to whom this is appropriate how long you
expect to do that how it aligns with the
curriculum standards and what are the
objectives and whatnots on that and I'm
kind of going through that process but
so that's an activity to do another idea
idea that I find interesting is this a
computational essays and you can read
more about Stephens ideas what is the
computational essay from his blog but
that's really an opportunity after you
do an activity it's an opportunity to
kind of reflect on that activity for the
student but also it provides for the
educators the opportunity to actually
access and form evaluation and so for
instance how our computation let's say
for this bike lock could look like that
you can actually really just kind of
write down in words what did you do in
the activity kind of describe what you
had there but then actually have that
interactive content that that and that
the user can or a teacher can then then
play with untested it works the way it
should and in a sense you can also then
like integrate it into Auto grading
system and things like that and I think
it's a very powerful way of both it's
useful for the student to actually go to
the reflection process and it can be for
the educators useful for for assessing
that from the warm side of things
computational thinking initiative design
is kind of um under the umbrella of law
firm foundation which is a non-profit
arm of work from research and which has
objective to support education research
and entrepreneurship now under
computational thinking initiative
it's actually a set of initiatives which
comprises at the moment computer-based
math which is mostly based in the UK and
the team is based in the UK and that's
kind of a top-down approach like they
interact with governments and try to
integrate computational thinking
curriculum into to be a core part in
public education and there is a one
trial going on and in Estonia right now
and there's really really good some good
good feedback coming from that another
set of initiatives is this kind of
individual lesson plans that we just
kind of went through we call them AI
adventures and this is a really an
activity that the individual teacher can
integrate into you into into classroom
and into what what they are doing it so
it can be a classroom activity or
after-school activity however it best
suits the the particular teacher school
ai League is an idea that there we have
a continuous flow of this these
individual activities so every week or
every month you will have you will have
throughout the school year these type of
activities and AI camp is an intensive
so it's a one week or in two weeks the
skills and educators can can come
together and do do these activities and
the idea of AI Arts and Science Fair is
that at the end of each year the
students and educators can kind of come
together and showcase what they have
done throughout the year now there's a
new initiative a computational thinking
org which is kind of the portal to
provide resources to everyone so it
includes the educational aspect but also
goes beyond education to provide
opportunities and resources
computational how to integrate
computational thinking into government
activities organizations and in industry
so some updates from the computational
thinking so these are the grassroot
efforts so about AI adventures there are
some publicly available now and so any
you can just go there and use them you
can either use it on an in cloud
notebook or download on your on your
machine and there are several under
development and there's material
available if you want to develop your
own to you you can contact me or others
at the CGI yeah to see you to you get
additional materials there are annual
camps so there's a high school summer
camp each year held since 2012 and
welcome and if this year we had a first
camp in Australia to you and there's a
plan to do another one in spring 2019
about leaks so last year we had three
leagues this year we have 13 and the
objective for next year would be kind of
to triple that so we're kind of we don't
want to scale this up like exponentially
before we actually you know have enough
understanding of what what is actually
affected affected ways and for that we
want to really focus on teacher training
and professional development so that
these educators can dance
themselves then have a ability to
initiate these programs in their own own
locations and kind of in a process we
are also working on identifying and
testing what metrics are best to measure
the the computational thinking
comprehension so first time this year in
spring we had like actual professional
development even serious events with
with full set of educators from from
covering four different time zone and if
you're interested in that there's gonna
be next in the spring so again you can
come with me to the CTI website we also
had like these kind of educator
roundtables which our webinars every
couple of months which cover topics like
how to integrate this into your
classroom and their example from from
educators that they tell how they are
doing and it's kind of a roundtable
thing and so there have been this almost
400 students 60 educators and spent
almost six thousand hours in total so
far and again we just want our next year
kind of double it up and offer more
opportunities throughout the throughout
the year so at the end I want to kind of
show
some resources or how you could advance
computational thinking so if you're an
educator you can again read the Stephens
blog about how to integrate that but
also you can then I encourage you to
actually create this educator content
that is computable so you can do it
truly in k-12 to the CTI activities
let's say the English lesson plans and
these different types of events and in
college and university level there is a
computational curriculum development
platform which being developed by Kyle
Keene at work from an MIT so that's it's
been used at MIT but it is an open
source so you can also use it in your
activities one simple way is I think I
find it's interesting is at least
challenges which is also came out
recently and some snippets of things
that you can kind of easily integrate
into you into your teaching activities
notice then you can share opportunities
that are offered directly for the
students like wall from student
certification mentorship and ambassador
problems so now if you're in researcher
again I would encourage you to actually
create this kind of interactive
computable publications and so instead
of having these static static PDF files
or whatnot you would actually have
content that is accessible by people and
that itself helps advance computational
thinking and and I encourage researchers
particularly engage the public in their
research so do you citizen science
projects and in a way that they are also
integrating these ideologies and just a
couple of words about it or any
organization if you're in a management
position position or an employee
basically these computational thinking
skills are kind of a core that will help
improve your organization in general you
can you'll be these people will be who
have these skills they are able to
handle complexities and identify
relevant concepts crafts useful
interesting questions come up with
creative new solutions and and and
communicate them effectively with each
other
one way practical way would be let's say
using these demonstration
if you have a meeting and you need to
present something make a demonstration
interactive demonstration about it you
can share it with the team beforehand
and showcase it in your meeting it's one
simple way of integrating it like yet
you can do right away so finally now we
can how you can actually get it out
there we have now notebook archive.org
which which you can actually make that
content accessible to everyone is this
ready made and you can also become a
certified in these things through to
Wolfram and Wolfram foundation you can
become certified computational educator
essentially or become an instructor if
you want to learn that's a good way of
if you're not entirely comfortable with
or from language that's a good way of
also kind of becoming very very
comfortable with it if you get certified
in that and my time is running out but
one way so you can become data curator
or community ambassador like like I am
so you get to give talks in the
conferences like this meets wonderful
interesting people the last slide is
basically is I've given here some
resources that you may find helpful from
the introduction she wore from lammle
it's well from University it's a MOOC
type thing basically where it covers all
the topics that have covered in the in
this conference I really want to
emphasize the more from summer school I
went there myself last year and was an
instructor this year and it's if you
really want to address a work on a
problem our project that you have in
mind is it's a really good place in
three weeks you can kind of focus on
that in an environment which is very
inspiring and and it's it's it's fun to
be with and it's Wolfram community where
you can ask and answer questions and I
have collected some resources in this
website you can you can go to if you
find it useful so I'd like to conclude
this talk and in fact in this conference
at least in this room by quoting the
Wolfram brothers so what comes to
computational thinking the magic is in
optimizing how process computer and
human can be put together to solve
increasingly tough problems and
computation thing thinking will be a
defining feature of the future and
children need to learn it now and in
to ensure success later on and I would
just like to kind of add that the
children of all ages I think it will be
very important and and part of each one
of our our today and the future thank
you
[Applause]